so be a dad again I got a no which is
harder because we know how difficult it
is to be an action hero but it's pretty
difficult to be a dad to three girls
which is harder oh by far this is cake
you know which is case that this the
movie making yes is cake I mean the idea
of being a daddy to three girls varying
ages by the way sixteen two and a half
and now you know a baby yeah baby but
there's but there's nothing better
really nothing better cuz you know
there's a special unique bond between a
dad and his little girl it's the hardest
what is the hardest yeah the hardest for
me what I'm realizing is is just being
ten steps ahead and always making sure
that you're ten steps ahead just in
terms of especially when things go
sideways and they start to feel that you
know if a temperature goes high a little
bit or they start to get sick a little
bit just thinking ten steps ahead
because then your instincts kick in your
daddy instincts kick in right and your
parent instincts so it's like you want
to you're always in you're trying to
work and you're trying to maintain
relationships and business probably
getting ready to start dating and some
but don't say that keeping up with Wayne
in this movie I mean you got to do the
action scenes with him yeah I'm
absolutely terrified it was actually the
green screen which was the hardest for
me because it's like imagining all this
stuff it doesn't exist all you've got a
tennis balls in there in the room and
that's what you've got to react and
against and that was really really hard
one of our first scenes together we were
inside of the helicopter when the the
most intense scene of the movie when the
entire building is going down and were
auto-rotating down with the with it and
in that you know there's there's
multiple looks you know Brad screaming
out tennis ball five to eight not you
know and you have to act I just remember
her take one she goes now this is like
I'm sure she felt very uncomfortable in
a moment and I had suggested that you
should go watch playback because you
know if you're unsure of something but
obviously I think after you watch play
last night we talked about names for the
new baby
you Tia you said was an option but you
didn't give me the other one well they
are Naomi I can't give that one away you
can't but Bhatia is on the board yes you
like it yeah it's pretty right and
waiting I knew you were gonna we were
going to get married in the spring and
then we got pregnant and Lauren felt
like well you know what I don't know if
I wanna if momma wants to take pictures
you know in being pregnant and wedding
dress so we're just gonna wait and I'm
not going to sure when but I know it's
gonna happen you know it's gonna do it
you know do it
shortly after having the baby or are you
going to shortly because right now I
still have to after this wish you Jungle
Cruise with Emily Blunt and then I go on
to shoot the Hobbs movie and we're just
trying to figure out when we can put it
in but the great thing is with Lauren I
mean she's such a rockstar and she's
just like it's alright whatever it's
gonna happen we're gonna make it work
I mean she's saying that now Hey
you